i'm here with Igor Bruce akoo possibly
has the newest job in austria in FTTH
eagle thanks for talking to me you are
looking after a coordination center for
FDA th what's that all about so this is
all about providing rural areas with
sustainable broadband connectivity okay
I tell me a bit more I mean so what does
that mean what are the issues I think
you're you're looking after a deeply
rural area yes that's right so lower
austria is the biggest austrian state
it's everything which is surrounding
vienna so we have about 1.6 million
inhabitants but it's only 85 inhabitants
per square kilometer so we are really
rural areas we have over 750,000
households and we have over 80,000 small
and medium-sized enterprises all right
she got a combination there really and
what so what are the main challenges in
actually providing services with that
spread of the the main challenge I think
in law Austria is the same as for any
other who rural areas and the challenge
is that we are providing right now
broadband with existing telephone
networks and the challenge is that these
telephone networks are not built for
broadband so trying to provide broadband
with telephone networks has limitations
and this is what the companies in Lower
Austria and everywhere else in rural
errors are experiencing every day I
would say so what we now are doing is
that we have put our goals not into the
direction of providing broadband but in
providing infrastructure we have now in
lower Austrian infrastructure goal right
and and and by this we will provide a
sustainable solution for this broadband
problem so we have changed we have
really changed our our viewpoint we have
we have changed of you for 180 degrees
okay now when we have an infrastructure
problem it's a completely different way
how you approach this problem because
infrastructure is something we are
dealing with the last how many hundred
years so and I think you've already made
some progress though yes the progress is
that there are five million euros
available for making a proof of concept
because only providing infrastructure of
course is not enough you have to have
negative infrastructure you have to have
also return of invest because even if
this is an infrastructure problem you
cannot build it without money and for
being attractive for for infrastructure
investment investors you have to have
returned so there have to be some some
input coming so only digging and also
only putting in some fiber or ducks into
the into the air without activating the
fiber will not bring you revenues so we
have more than our model is more than
just putting ducts into the ground our
model is also how to activate the
passive infrastructure how to enable
full competition on the service provider
level so in our model which is the free
long model from the guy from the UK
guide of Broughton investment we are
strictly separating the layers passive
infrastructure active net network
operator who is wholesale only operator
yeah and then the service providers who
are the existing local national
international service provider so it's
really totally transparent and totally
open to every service provider this is a
very well-known model at the at the
Nordic countries yeah absolutely well
let's hope you can repeat the success of
the Nordic countries in the meantime
thank you very much for talking to us
you're welcome so interesting news there
from Austria where it's all about
infrastructure